-I think one thing
that Donald Trump
might be counting on is
the strength of the econom
right now.
It's certainly something
he talks about a lot.
It came up a couple times in the
debate asking people on stage,
"How do you respond to
the strong stock market,
low unemployment?"
But you actually think
the economy
could be a good talking poin
for Democrats.
-Yeah, I mean,
if you look at the polling
it is the one issue that he'
12 points up in approval on.
I think there's a case to be
made for Democrats
to make the case
about why this economy
isn't actually working for
a lot of people.
I mean, you've got
a trillion-dollar tax cut.
You've had huge amounts of
stock buy-backs.
You don't have a lot of
business investment.
The fact of the matter is
economic development continues
to be intensely concentrated
in a relatively small
geographic area.
That was the whole critiqu
against the Obama economy
back in 2016 when Donald Trump
sort of banged on about that
about bad trade deals.
There's a GM plant
that closed this week
10 miles from the debate,
in Warren.
In Lordstown, Ohio,
Donald Trump --
you should watch this clip -
he gets up in front of Lordstown
and he says to them,
"This plant's
not going anywhere.
Don't sell your home."
Don't sell your home,
don't do anything.
They shut the plant down.
Like, the same
structural factors,
and then you put on top of tha
some of the trade war stuff,
which has really hammered
a lot of farmers,
I think there's a case to be
made about why the Trump economy
is not as good as it looks
for a lot of working people,
and I would like to see
Democrats make that case.
-And why do you think
it's not something
they've picked up on yet?
-I think you see them
try to start to make it,
but what ends up happening
in these debates, particularly
is they're competing with
each other,
so they're focused on area
where they have areas
of agreement or disagreement
or a tax.
I do think that Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren
and Joe Biden, to some extent,
when Biden talked about
the auto rescue tonight,
when he was asked the question
"How are you gonna
win Michigan?"
He talked about the auto rescue,
which is a good thing to do,
because the auto rescue wa
amazingly important
and effective piece of
policy intervention
that saved tens of thousands o
jobs across the greater Midwest.
-Climate change came up tonigh
as well.
This is an issue you're gonn
do a special on.
-Yeah, we're doing
a two-day forum
with as many candidates
as we can get.
-I imagine preparing for tha
must be difficult in that
the breadth of things
you have to talk about
when you're talking about
the climate is so vast.
-It is. It's a hard thing
to zero in on.
It's also hard to
sort of move between
the specialized vocabulary o
people
that are in the world of climate
policy or climate activism
and what the broader publi
knows.
So I think
it takes a lot of work
to get really good conversations
going on
that a lot of times
also politicians
just don't know that much abou
it, frankly.
They know the briefing book.
Jay Inslee is an exception
I did a podcast with him,
why is this happening,
where he talked for an hou
about this stuff.
This is what he's running on
But a lot of them can't ge
too far out past
their briefing book on it.
That's not the case in something
like, for instance,
criminal justice reform,
immigration, or healthcare
All are issues I feel
that the majority of candidate
have more facility with
than at this point
they do climate policy.
-And do you think part of that
too is just the massivenes
of the undertaking to fix
where the climate is heading
-Did you hear the Andrew Yan
answer tonight?
Andrew Yang
was asked about climate,
and he said, "Oh, probably not
gonna fix it.
You're gonna need to move
your family to higher ground
so we're giving you
$1,000 a month."
[ Laughter ]
That's bleak, buddy.
-That was real bleak, yeah
He had some nice moments tonight
but that was a tough one.
-It was bleak.
I don't think $1,000 a month i
going to do it,
if you need to go
to higher ground.
But what I did think about tha
is it did puncture a little bi
of the kind of like,
"We can do it, we can do it.
Being clear-eyed about wha
we're up against right now
is really important,
and it's very hard to do tha
and balance that
with the kind of hopefulness
that is necessary
to kind of motivate people
and sort of put together
a coalition you need.
-You've never moderated
a debate.
You would like to.
It seems to be
an impossible undertaking.
-It is an impossible job
that I would love to have.
I mean, really, it is impossible
I know.
You watch a debate,
you watch people on Twitter,
or you talk to family member
who are very critical of
how the debate is managed,
which just goes with
the territory.
-Of course.
-With that many people,
you got 10 people on stage
You're trying to be fair
in distributing talking time
Politicians talk long.
It's hard to get
fruitful exchanges.
It's hard to cut people off.
And then when things go long
I saw people complaining about
how long the CNN debate went
but it's like,
it's either gonna go long
or they're gonna cut them off,
right?
Or you do fewer topics.
If you do fewer topics,
then people say,
"Oh, you didn't get this topic
this topic, this topic."
So a huge part of the challenge,
particularly at this point
in the cycle,
is just managing
that many people on stage.
You've got
a choir's worth of people
that you got to deal with.
I think later on if you've got
four or five people,
you can get something.
-And that will happen one day,
right?
It'll get down to four or five
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, I think so.
-Okay, good.
-What's really interesting to me
is what's the over/under o
the number of people still in it
by February 6th or wheneve
the Iowa caucus is.
-Yeah. Eight.
Over/under is eight.
-I think somewhere around 10
probably is probably the answer.
-Well, come back then.
Let's talk about it.
Thanks so much for coming here
in the middle of the night
Chris Hayes, everybody.